[Music]  a new project called the watermark is  hoping to bring some life back to  downtown henderson  it's a massive 50 million development  the watermark is modeled after another  popular downtown district area across  the country  there will be space for apartments  officers entertainment plenty of  restaurants  the hope is to bring new people to the  area match the feel of the new downtown  especially with the other properties  like lifeguard arena  i really think it's going to change the  dynamic of water street i mean  with with the two buildings standing  face to face with the activities in  between  you know we've our design is really  going to complement the design across  the street  and i think it's going to create a  wonderful space to be  the watermark expected to be completed  by early next year